welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the end credits of Star Wars
Ahsoka are gorgeously constructed and
filled with secrets from planets on a
star map in an ancient runic language
that I actually figured out how to
translate and these translations
actually spell out the path to paridia
to the letter reframe what we know about
Star Wars and bring up some other visual
details from episode 2 that we missed
like in addition to hearing per goal on
ctOS Bale and skull actually saw one
moving in the clouds hell yeah let's do
this and by the way if you are watching
Ahsoka and you've never seen Rebels and
you kind of need a cheat sheet we are
doing a four-part Rebels recap series on
this channel and while you should watch
all of rebels just watching these videos
will catch you up with what you really
need to know to truly appreciate Ahsoka
okay the closing credits of every
episode depict the path to paridia
described by bailing skull in episode 2
as a fairy tale told by children in the
Jedi Temple but confirmed by night
sister Morgan elspeth to be based on
truth and these golden lines take us
through the known Star Wars Universe to
the unknown Galaxy that this series is
expanding to visually this may remind
you of the branching bloodline animation
of the House of the Dragon opening
titles and it does something similar but
instead of individuals on a family tree
we are seeing Star Wars planets and how
they connect on this yellow brick road
now when I first saw these runes I did
not recognize them as any known Star
Wars written language like orabesh or
mandoa covering these shows for so long
on YouTube I've gotten pretty good at
recognizing orabesh and mandoa both of
those are alphabets with one-to-one
correlations with the 26 letters of the
English alphabet at this point I can
kind of look at an orbish word and
Eyeball it know what it is I know it's
probably not a healthy thing now with
this new runic language it seems like
it's a language of the ancient
civilization that this series is
branching back to so we don't already
have an alphabet for these runes and we
had to work backwards to figure out what
that alphabet is how does one do this
well three years ago when the teaser for
the Robert Patton said Batman movie came
out we saw the Riddler's clue with a
cipher and I within a few hours was able
to figure out what the answer to that
riddle was and the first thing you do
when you see a cipher like this is you
look for double letters and then you try
to apply that to words that might
already exist in the answer word or
answer phrase in this case the answer
was he lies still and starting with a
double L we're able to get the L by the
T the S it's basically cryptography 101
pretty rudimentary stuff it's basic
substitution and you just kind of use
your logic your Wheel of Fortune your
crossword skills and the number of
letters in a word to figure out what it
would be so here in these closing
credits there are 20 visible words in
this runic language and knowing that it
is the path to paridia
p-e-r-i-d-e-a according to Disney plus
closed captioning that is seven letters
and I think it's a safe assumption the
Final Destination point in this
animation is peridia and these seven
runes apply to the seven letters of
paridia so as we work to fill in our
alphabet that gives us a p an e an r and
i a d and an a which is pretty good we
got three vowels there and an r a very
common consonant now since ctOS was
defined as the reflex Point planet in
episode two I thought at first that
might be the first planet we see but the
runes do not line up this word begins
and ends in an A so then I realized oh
this must be Arcana the location of the
night sister temple in episode 1 which
cool adds to our alphabet a c and an n
and being another very common letter and
then as I looked around the sequence I
realized citas must actually be the
third of the last one number 17. the one
surrounded by a pergol constellation the
E and the a lineup and the first and the
last letter are the same so that must be
our s and great now we also have an S A
T and an O and we are well on our way
folks but the cool thing about this
planet being surrounded by a big perkal
hyperspace whale on the star map is if
you re-watch that scene with Balin on
citas closely when he looks up past the
column at the sky I pointed out my
breakdown of this episode that you can
hear a Pergo call but you can also see a
pergol shadow shifting around the clouds
especially when you brighten that region
so just a reminder that the migratory
path of the pergol is the path to
paridia they lead the path to another
galaxy so from here I was able to figure
out most of the alphabet of these runes
and I used it to translate all of the
planets that we see all of the runes and
it's pretty interesting how this ancient
map charts everything out especially if
you watch the rebels season 3 finale
where the character of grand Admiral
thrawn applies his own ancient star map
to the current Galactic map to
triangulate the position of atalon this
guy is all about ancient star Maps he
has a map that you can layer on top of
our map to open up new Pathways and I
think that's what this series is doing
so the first planet we see as the
animation begins is Arcana as I
mentioned that's the planet with a nice
sister Temple that we see in episode 1
the second planet translates to iron
i-e-r-n-e that's a new planet to Star
Wars that we haven't heard of yet but
down at the bottom of the screen is a
third marking its last three letters of
a word ending in rmm I'm not sure what
that is but then the path strikes two
planets and branches downward through
another Circle striking two more planets
and then speeds into a ring with a loath
wolf in the background which is
important because in Star Wars Rebels
season 4 two-dimensional loath wolves
like this are what led Ezra Bridger to
the world Between Worlds a realm that
can transcend the boundaries of time
itself I like mobile games but sometimes
I want something casual that I can dip
in and out of all day long rather than
having to really focus on for an hour at
a time and right now my casual game of
choice is pocket Champs pocket Champs is
free to download on an iOS or Android
and it is so fun and pocket Champs
you're in charge of training the champ
so that they can beat other Champs and
races on obstacle courses every course
is different but you've got a bunch of
gadgets to choose from to make sure that
your champ has a leg up on the
competition the upgrading and
progression is super satisfying
particularly when it lets you eke out
some close wins so in this race I use my
wings because there'd be a lot of flying
that green guy on the skateboard almost
got me but then right at the end boom
first place pocket Champs is super fun
if you want to play it yourself click
the link in the description below or
scan the QR code on the screen you'll
get a free starter pack with 1 100 gems
to upgrade your gadgets added to your
account on September 4th but only if you
download before the third now on the
border of this ring at the top of the
screen it says perlemian trade route
that is a hyperspace trade route that
connects Felucia and tanab that's
referenced by the bad badge it's an old
Tarkin favorite but the top middle of
this screen in here gorrell that is the
planet that showed up several times in
Rebels it's supposed to be relatively
close to low fall and sure enough to the
lower right of this is lothal
l-o-t-h-a-l this is the recurring
setting in Rebels it's a home of Ezra
Bridger very important planet and yes
it's seen in live action in Ahsoka
episodes one and two directly to the
right of lothal is another planet and
then past that Mandalore
m-a-n-d-a-l-o-r-e doomed Homeworld the
Mandalorian people seen in Mandalorian
season 3 and in Clone Wars and Rebels
another very important Planet then we
Branch into an area with three visible
planets the path actually bypasses
agamar which is actually a rocky planet
that the ghost crew visited with Rex and
the rebel season 3 episode the last
battle this was the site of a past Clone
Wars battle and then the path hits in
the middle of a ring dathomir ooh so
this is the home of maul and it is a
place where night sister Temple stood it
was seen in Clone Wars with the night
sister mother thousand reanimated Maul's
legs and of course it was the temple
where Ezra Maul Canaan Sabine went into
in Rebel season 3 and recovered the
darksaber now interestingly right above
dathomir very close to it is Yavin this
is the gas giant with the moon of Yavin
4 where the rebel base stood didn't
realize zathomir and Yavin were this
close then the path branches deeper into
a whole other area and the center of
this ring is corellia this is the
industrial Planet seen in episode 2 also
in Solo a Star Wars story in the top
Center of this area that translates to
keto nemoidia that's the wealthy home of
the neymorians from the prequels in the
Clone Wars era below that is Duro
d-u-r-o the populated home of the duros
race and then beneath that surprised
that it was this close to anything
pasana
p-a-s-a-a-n-a that is the desert planet
that we see in the rise of Skywalker
where they recover the dagger and Rey
thinks she kills Chewbacca I thought
that was way further away from
everything else now that large curved
band that we see to the right those
runes translate to corellian run the
famous hyperspace Lane used by Smugglers
now our Gold Line path branches downward
to what I assume are the core worlds of
this galaxy because it intersects with
the center World which is Coruscant
c-o-r-u-s-c-a-n-t and now finally we
arrive at our reflex point of seatas it
is surrounded by the pergol which really
starts the pathway to pritia the path
branches rightward through two crescent
shapes the first one is unmarked but the
second one translates to Odin o-d-y-n
why is this important well balance skull
in shinhati are named after the Norse
mythological wolves that chase the Sun
and Moon across the sky Odin ODI and
different spelling is the Supreme Norse
God we see loath wolves on the lothal
mural that's been painted even the
character of maroc gets his name from
Arthurian Legend a character associated
with Wolves I'm telling you wolf imagery
is everywhere in this and I think this
Odin planet's gonna have some connection
to Balin and shin now the far right
planet is something Anna u n n a maybe
Zuna based on the consonants I still
haven't figured out yet now the line
here passes several shimmering Pergo and
several lines intersect at her final
destination paridia so peridia is in a
separate Galaxy think about it all of
Star Wars until now has been a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away one Galaxy
with some unknown regions but still one
Galaxy this is a second Galaxy
altogether and that's a huge deal it
means that this era of Star Wars stories
might actually take place in history
unaffected by the events of the sequel
Trilogy and that Ahsoka and the
crossover movie that Dave filoni is
working toward do not have to tie into
the rise of the first order or the
Palpatine cloning plot or snoke
Starkiller base any of that it could be
a whole new horizon of planets dominated
by thrawn let me know in the comments
below your thoughts on all this but
please support new rock stars with this
Ahsoka inspired fulcrum shirt available
at nerdriot.shop And subscribe to the
break room for Ira Ahsoka after shows
I'll subscribe to the Deep dive and
don't forget to use our Link in the
description below to download Pocket
chance and get a free starter pack you
can follow me at eavos thank you so much
for watching I'll see you next time bye
[Music]
thank you